just want to bring you some breaking
news and we're hearing that Steve Mackey
the bass player in the band pole has
died at the age of 56 the band's members
have been paying tribute to their
beloved friend today saying he made
things happen they shared a photo on
Instagram uh conferring that he passed
away this morning no further details
have been given but a lovely story
behind this photo
um this is from when Pope Bronto in
South America in 2012 at the band saying
we had a day off and Steve suggests we
go climbing in the Andes so we did and
it's a completely magical experience far
more magical than staring at the hotel
room wall all day which is probably what
we'd have done otherwise Steve made
things happen in this life in his life
and in the band and we'd very much like
to think that he's back in those
mountains now on the next stage of his
adventures safe travels Steve so that is
Pulp announcing the death of their bass
guitarist Steve Mackey